même lieu même et lui même message le
jeu des sept erreurs en presque parfait
pour ses discours à deux semaines
d'intervalle
qui sera capable de faire à notre place
tout ce que nous réalisons pourquoi
détruire ce qui marche pour rafistoler
ce qui ne marche pas
les élus d'ile-de-france ne lâchent pas
leur vision du grand paris alors que les
annonces du gouvernement se font
toujours attendre
pour eux la réforme de la métropole ne
peut entraîner la suppression des
départements et doit s'élargir à toute
la région un enjeu qu'ils estiment
crucial pour le développement des
territoires des grands investissements
ne se feront pas avoir six ou dans la
grande couronne se fera en priorité ce
qu'on appelle la petite couronne la
petite ceinture et on ne peut pas avoir
au sein de l'ile-de-france un nouveau
périphérique la grande couronne dont
nous faisons partie est une évidence et
nécessité aujourd'hui pour un équilibre
ça nous permettrait également d'éviter
les mille feuilles qui sont aujourd'hui
est difficile à comprendre
invité d'honneur du rassemblement 500
élus locaux et des représentants de la
société civile moi la notion des
départements me parle
la notion de la région me parle la
notion de métropole me parle beaucoup
moins chefs d'entreprises responsables
d'associations partenaires sociaux ils
ont tous justifier l'importance du
département et tenter de mettre la
pression pour l'avenir et là on a voulu
que des chefs d'entreprise et
responsables associatifs des
travailleurs sociaux
bref qu'il celles et ceux qui savent
l'indispensable nécessité du département
puisse s'exprimer
je crois qu'ils ont fait avec leurs mots
et surtout avec leur exemple prochaine
action des départements d'île de france
mercredi 7 février avec une fermeture
des services publics
les décisions du gouvernement sont elles
attendues une semaine plus tard